The post-processing step in a question
answering task. When doing question answering,
the processing of the initial dataset implies
splitting examples in several features, which
may or may not contain the answer. Passing those
features through the model will give us logits for
the start and end positions, since our labels are
the indices of the tokens that correspond to the
start and end the answer. We must then somehow
convert those logits into an answer, and then
pick one of the various answers each feature
gives to be THE answer for a given example.
For the processing step, you should refer
to the video linked below. It's not very
different for validation, we just need to
add a few lines to keep track of two things:
instead of discarding the offset mapping,
we keep them, and also include in them the
information of where the context is by setting
the offsets of the special tokens and the question
to None. Then we also keep track
of the example ID for each feature,
to be able to map back feature to the
examples that they originated from.
If you don't want to compute the validation loss,
you won't need to include all the special code
that we used to create the labels. With this done,
we can apply that preprocessing function using the
map method. We take the SQUAD dataset like in
the preprocessing for question-answering video.
Once this is done, the next step is to create
our model. We use the default model behind the
question-answering pipeline here, but you
should use any model you want to evaluate.
We will run a manual evaluation loop, so we
create a PyTorch DataLoader with our features.
With it, we can compute and gather all
the start and end logits like this,
with a standard PyTorch evaluation loop. With this
done, we can really dive into the post-processing.
We will need a map from examples to
features, which we can create like this.
Now, for the main part of the post-processing,
let's see how to extract an answer from the
logits. We could just take the best index for the
start and end logits and be done, but if our model
predicts something impossible, like tokens in
the question, we will look at more of the logits.
Note that in the question-answering pipeline,
we attributed score to each answer based on the
probabilities, which we did not compute here.
In terms of logits, the multiplication we had
in the scores becomes an addition. To go fast, we
don't look at all possible start and end logits,
but the twenty best ones. We ignore the logits
that spawn impossible answers or answer that are
too long. As we saw in the preprocessing,
the labels (0, 0) correspond to no answer,
otherwise we use the offsets to get the answer
inside the context. Let's have a look at the
predicted answer for the first feature, which
is the answer with the best score (or the best
logit score since the SoftMax is an increasing
function). The model got it right! Next we just
have to loop this for every example, picking for
each the answer with the best logit score in all
the features the example generated. Now you know
how to get answers from your model predictions!